Speaker 1: A judge has ordered armed gunmen
away from ballot drop boxes, but not all the
way away.
Just 250 feet away.
You're allowed to intimidate at ballot drop
boxes in Arizona as long as you do it from
250 feet away.
If you have been following this story as we
have, we started to see armed.
What do we call them?
They're armed.
So they are gunmen.
Is it a militia?
I don't know.
Not really.
Armed people claiming to be poll watchers
showing up in and around ballot drop boxes
in Arizona.
In some cases, we have video of confrontations
with people just dropping off ballots.
Of course, immediately the courts were brought
into this.
And HuffPost and the Associated Press now
report judge orders armed group away from
Arizona ballot drop boxes.
Local and federal law enforcement have been
alarmed by reports of people, some armed,
watching 24 hour ballot boxes in two counties.
And a federal judge yesterday ordered the
armed members of this group to stay at least
250 feet away from the locations following
complaints that people wearing masks all of
a sudden they want to wear masks and carrying
guns were intimidating voters.
Wow.
U.S. District Court Judge Michael Liberti
also said members of Clean Elections USA,
its leader and anyone working with them are
barred from filming or following anyone within
75 feet of a ballot drop box or the entrance
of a building that houses one.
They also can't speak to or yell at people
within that perimeter unless spoken to first.
This is insanity.
This is absolute and total insanity.
Armed people monitoring drop boxes.
It is a dystopian, laughing stock, but we
kind of laugh to avoid crying, which is really
what we should be doing.
This is horrible.
This is you know, I don't want to use pejorative
terms, third world stuff or whatever.
This is completely unbecoming of the United
States.
And by the way, they can be there.
They just have to be 250 feet away.
It should have happened sooner and it should
be more than 250 feet.
Understand that 250 feet in many cases means
that they're allowed to be at the entrance
at this sort of driveway with the parking
lot, I guess you would call it, at the entrance
to the parking lot, to the bit, to the locations
of these ballot drop boxes.
It doesn't even really change anything.
Often you have a couple hundred feet, particularly
in Arizona, where things are so spread out
in many parts of the state.
So instead of seeing them right by the drop
box itself, you see the armed people as you're
driving in.
To where you would stop to put your ballots
in.
Apparently, the intimidation with guns is
okay and it's free speech as long as you're
250 feet away.
Now, there's a real question here.
This has had a chilling effect already.
Is the court decision too late?
Because at the end of the day, they're simply
being told you've got to be a little further
away.
And they still might have had the impact that
they want to have.
But this should scare all of us.
And Arizona is the big state in which we've
learned about this happening for now.
I am monitoring for stories of it happening
in other states.
And if you come across any, please do let
me know.
But this is you know, the court is determining
whether what is being done violates the letter
of the law.
What I am more concerned with is that all
of this and this dates back to six months
before the 2020 election, when they started
to hint that if we lose, it's rigged and the
mail in ballots are fraud and all this different
stuff that the spirit of what it should be
to have an election in the United States of
America has, of course, been violated by all
of this nonsense going all the way back.
Let me know what you think.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We'll take a very quick break and be right
back.
The David Pakman Show is a viewer and listener
funded program.
I would really love it, particularly at this
critical, critical time for independent media
as we have a very important election coming
and an even more important election potentially
after that.
I would love for you to sign up at join Packman
dot com.
You can use the coupon code.
Big voting 22 for six more days.
Get the discount.
Get the bonus show.
Speaker 2: The bonus show where you want to
make money.
Speaker 3: Everybody else who makes money
to fund themselves is back.
Speaker 1: Get all of.
Speaker 3: It.
Thank your lucky stars every day.
You're not de facto.
Speaker 1: And you still won't be.
Dave Pacman.
Sign up it.
Join Pacman dot com.
We'd love to see you there